bonsoir
regardez la personne qui est à votre
droite puis la personne qui est à votre
gauche vous ne connaissez peut-être pas
encore cette personne alors que
peut-être elle pourra vous aider dans
dix ans demain tout à l'heure on est
tous autant que nous sommes des héros du
quotidien dans les épreuves dans nos
milieux socio culturelles
professionnelles ainsi que dans la
sphère privée dans la vie en fin de
compte
batman par exemple c'est un super héros
phénoménal il sauve le monde tous les
jours et pourtant pourtant il est comme
comme vous et moi il ya la pression et
peut-être que vous justement aussi dans
votre travail vous avez eu la pression
aujourd'hui il ya les horaires de
travail les congés qu'on a ou justement
qu'on n'a pas l'âge du diplôme moi ma
pression moi ça a été quand quand j'ai
travaillé travaillé pour obtenir mon
cours d'orthophonie à l'école de tours
et j'étais admise
j'ai été admise
j'ai fait deux ans
et puis le 6 janvier 2016
patatras un médecin m'a diagnostiqué une
déficience d'attention importante et une
mémoire déjà pathologique pour un jeune
âge alors ce ce 6 janvier 2016
gt gt effondré quoi et puis et puis je
me suis posée j'ai pleuré de joie entier
et je me suis dit on en janvier on est
en début d'année il faut bouger
maintenant et j'ai bougé je suis là ce
soir
et si celui-là c'est aussi grâce à plein
de super héros pendant toute ma vie qui
m'ont fait du bien et du coup je me suis
dit que cette année j'avais envie
j'avais envie d'aider et on baladant sur
twitter j'ai découvert leur hyper calme
et ray park a fait autrement dit c'est
un endroit vraiment super où les gens un
peu les gens en qu'on peut croiser
partout des gens du quotidien se
retrouvent pour réparer les choses
bénévolement ils se disent tiens
pourquoi moi je serai pas moi même un
super héros donc ils réparent les objets
du quotidien et ils se rendent pas
compte que justement la cafetière qu'il
répare elle pourra peut-être servir à
une famille entière
donc j'ai vu passer des aspirateurs les
faire passer et même une fois une
tondeuse et le projet m'a vraiment bien
plus et je me suis proposé pour faire
leur communication et on m'a dit oui
enfin on m'a dit oui et je vous parle
d'ordinateur nous avons pensé à mon
petit frère qui est une sorte de super
héros en fait de l'informatique pour moi
parce qu'il se réparer les ordinateurs
en moins de deux heures j'ai parlé de
mon frère san appel à parler de la
famille dans la famille aussi il ya une
pression énorme
et quand j'ai dû arrêter mes études en
janvier je pense que j'avais peut-être
plus peur de décevoir ma famille que de
me décevoir moi même et puis c'est
pareil dans les réunions de famille on
est tous à se retrouver les cousinades
les grands repas les anniversaires ou on
tousse un bourg aussi chouette
eh ben il ya toujours les petites mamies
qui sont là à dire mais quand est ce que
tu te maries donc tout ça ça m'amène à
penser que que la famille s'est pas
seulement la pression et heureusement la
famille c'est c'est du soutien
et il soutient tout ça le ciment bah
c'est l'amour
et je me rends compte voilà qu'il ya des
super héros un peu partout on peut en
croiser au khyber café dans nos familles
et comme on a tous une famille unie
forcément dans toutes les familles de
chacun d'entre vous ce soir et on peut
aussi en croisé totalement par hasard
et à ce propos je vous raconter une
petite anecdote
l'an dernier j'ai travaillé à center
parcs et j'avais dans mon équipe de
collègues
jonathan et bane outils et eux ils ne me
connaissaient pas et pourtant pourtant
ils m'ont dit oui aussi ils ont dit oui
à tous mes projets les initiatives
toutes mes démarches et ça et ça ça m'a
fait du bien parce que déjà il était sur
mon chemin de de finalement je veux pas
seulement aider les gens je veux les
rendre heureux et je me dis voilà qu'on
a tous nos héros touche chacun
différents dans notre histoire
et moi je suis vraiment fier d'avoir une
famille qui qui peut-être a mis du temps
pour mieux comprendre mais qui m'a
comprise et qui m'a dit un jour un jour
très clairement oui mais du moment que
ça te rend heureux et nous
et vous et je me dis que voilà un il m'a
dit que quelqu'un avait tous faire ce
soir
c'est comme planter des petites graines
on sait pas ce qu'elles vont devenir
ça fera peut-être des plants de haricots
ou des jolies roses
peut-être que justement la graine qu'on
va porter ce soir ça sera la mère d'une
d'une immense forêt alors alors
finalement la parente ça compte pas
c'est l'intention qui compte
alors ce qui compte c'est de dire oui de
dire merci de tendre la main
regardez la personne que vous avez à
votre droite puis la personne que vous
avez à votre gauche vous avez forcément
un super-héros assis juste à côté de
vous merci